I thought what I might do is go around
the room and you just introduce
yourselves to the media real quickly and
then we'll have a discussion afterwards
you know our 2.2 trillion dollar relief
package includes provisions to allow
businesses to deduct their losses this
year against taxes they paid in previous
years which gets you a lot of liquidity
and a lot of companies need the
liquidity right now and hopefully we're
going to be back in business very soon
we're going to be open very soon in this
country or was it built to be closed and
essentially we have a closed country
nobody's ever heard of a thing like this
but this was I was with some of the
leading professionals and they say not
since 1917 has it been anything like
this 1917 was a time when I guess you
could say 50 75 or 100 million you had
different estimates people died thinking
about a hundred million maybe a hundred
million people died so they had no
communications they weren't able to shut
things down like we are doing but that
would
there was a plague I was at playing
started here actually went to Europe we
were badly affected but Europe was
really affected so that was the worst
and so not since a hundred years ago
more than a hundred years ago has this
thing like this happened I just want to
start by saying it's an honor to be with
you I know most of you one way or the
other some of you I know and but I know
all of you by seeing you in the covers
of all the business magazines and the
magazines and you've done a great job
and we'll work this out and we'll get
our energy business back on with you a
thousand percent it's a great business
it's a very vital business and honestly
you've been very fair you've kept energy
prices reasonable for a long period of
time we've got a long period of time
with very reasonable energy prices so I
want to thank you all for being here and
maybe we'll start with Mike please all
right Mike work with seven corporation
mr. president proud where our people are
doing to support healthcare providers
first responders and all the other vital
industries that keep our economy going
thank you very much appreciate Vicky
Hall boxes in Tyrolean thank you for
allowing us to be here today and thank
you for all you're doing for us thank
you very much Thank You Vicky Dave Baker
Devon Energy or an independent oil and
gas company out of Oklahoma City thank
you so much for the leadership that
you're providing during this challenging
time you're the right man at the right
time to balance all the priorities and
we're gonna be back thank you very much
we'll get it done Dave thank you very
much mr. president Greg Garland total 66
again thank you for great leadership
through this pandemic crisis and all
that you've done on the STEMI wants this
package really for the American economy
the proper police are working to provide
energy and improve lives we think it's
going to come back quickly it's it's
ready we're ready and we've got the
right packages out there so very good
we're looking at a I think we're going
to be really looking very seriously in a
infrastructure package where it's so
important for our country you know as of
this moment Darren we have seven
trillion plus in the Middle East for
what for what reason and we don't put
money in our own countries so we're
going to do a big a big package on
infrastructure fairly soon and I think
and that's very important
yeah it's great for you the credit from
everybody Darren please
Thank You mr. president Darren woods
Exxon Mobil Corporation I'd like to add
my thanks for your leadership in this
space as well and say I think all of our
companies here are aligned with your
objective which is to get the economy
moving and to make make sure people's
lives around the world better we judge
you thank you Harold Hamm German
commented resources also out of Oklahoma
City I think we're having this meeting I
think this is so timely and necessary
really appreciate through leadership
also the friendship that you've kept
with the Saudis the Saudi foreign
minister or Crown Prince and also
vitomir Putin I know those hadn't been
easy sometimes but at this time it was
particularly needed so I represent our
company as well as the depa domestic
energy producers Alliance and we're
about the 10,000 companies and
individuals mostly independent producers
this great great job you're doing I
think President Putin and the crown
prince wants something to happen badly
certainly terrible for them what's
happening - so they want to see
something happen I've spoken to both of
them and we'll tell you about that a
little well thank you very much
yeah Thank You mr. president Jeff
Hildebrand founder chairman o Corp
energy our distinction is we are the
only private company here this is a
company that's based in Houston domestic
only exploration and production company
and I'm really here today to represent
the independent energy companies the
family-owned businesses that are that
are in this industry and to give you
really that perspective and add to the
conversation in that regard so thank you
for your leadership appreciate it Thank
You Ben mr. president helping Warren
Energy
we're the only papad company and so we
try to do business with everybody in
this room and and I think we
successfully do actually so it's an
honor to be here sir and it's an honor
to be in this room with these these
folks as well and everyone loves that
guy right thank you very much great
great job you doing - he's not an oil
and gas man he's a wonderful person and
a wonderful politician and he wants to
see the industry get strong again
so Kevin do you have anything to say by
the way well first I want to thank you
for doing this just by you reaching out
to President Putin and the Crown Prince
things have improved you're looking
around a lot of jobs but what else
you're not seeing at this table a lot of
these are small businesses that work
with all these individuals around here
and your action today with citing the
cares Act getting the small business
loans out is going very strongly because
it's needed but the American economy
greatest strength is our what energy
provides us you provide us a good price
these are great jobs but more
importantly it also gives us energy
independence it changes the whole
dynamics around
so thank you for the leadership thank
you Kevin unless you just said that Bank
of America in particular is really of
the big banks has really stepped into it
they have done a fantastic job today and
so over the ten thousand in the first
year thank you for marrying unbelievable
and I want to thank them I want to thank
all of the community banks and the
smaller banks that have been loaning a
lot of money paycheck it's all about the
paycheck and that nobody would have
believed to cut a gun so well so it's
it's just a number of hours but the
numbers are far greater than we would
have anticipated so it's been really
great and thank you to all the banks but
again in particular Bank of America they
really stepped right up and they did it
there were no big deals that won't make
it a big deal out of anything so that
was terrific and I think what we want to
do john cornyn please I know how you are
so involved in this coming from the
great state of Texas would you like to
say a couple of words Thank You mr.
president thank you for convening the
meeting many of us have been talking
together but we can't get done what
needs to be done only you and the
administration can and particularly
getting the attention of the Saudis and
flooding the markets really adding
insult to injury in a time when our
economy was suffering anyway because of
the corona virus and so this meeting
could not be more timely I agree with
what's been said about the importance of
affordable energy to our standard of
living and really we've changed the
changing the world as a result of the
production of domestic energy here and
improved the quality of life for a lot
of people
good job and John agrees we're talking
about it the other day that you've all
done well but you've also kept the
energy very affordable very very
affordable and very a lot of it we never
had any problems we're going to keep it
the way do I see Dan back there I was I
was looking I thought that looked like
Dan I want to thank you for convening
this meeting you know under the Trump
administration working with the Congress
the US has become the world's energy
superpower again it's unbelievable and
these companies have done it obviously
it's a very important issue in my state
the great state of Alaska but these are
great jobs as John Cornyn just said for
all of our states but it's really
important for the national security of
our country to and we have been a number
of senators have been reaching out
having frank discussions with the saudis
saying hey if you're a long-standing
ally of ours we're not right now you're
you're hurting a lot of our citizens
you're hurting a lot of the people we
represent and shouldn't take us for
granted we have a great military that's
protected Saudi Arabia for decades and
Senator Kramer and I have some
legislation that could possibly change
that if if they don't start to cooperate
so again we appreciate your leadership
with the crown prince with the Russians
and calling this meeting but this is a
great sector of the US economy that once
we get through this and we will this
pandemic this this sector is going to
take off again and your your
administration you have had a lot to do
with the strength of the US energy
sector and we need to keep it strong
thank you
and kevin cramer north dakota people
don't realize how big of produces North
Dakota is right mr. president
Decco everything and maybe a little bit
the people around your cavity but right
now we are part of the Renaissance of
oil and gas in this country but since
you became president we went from a
Renaissance to security to independence
to dominance and that dominance and that
security a right now are in some danger
just a quick example in North Dakota
since Saudi Arabia and Russia announced
their little price war we've had six
billion dollars of capex taken out of
our state plan for this year I was
economic developer after when the entire
gross domestic product of North Dakota
is 13 billion dollars so that's
significant that represents not just
capex that represents lots of jobs lots
of people in the value chain and we just
have one word took to what Dan talked
about with regard to Saudi Arabia it is
estimated by one report in 2018 that we
spend a minimum of eighty eighty 1
billion dollars defending global oil
supplies we can use that money in
national defense and other hotspots and
in the world if our friends are going to
treat us this way so appreciate your
outreach this week I think we're halfway
there just with the success of your
diplomacy this week thank you for
knowledge for this week if it's got out
we have to otherwise we do there's a lot
of jobs too we're talking about what is
a big job producers anyway Kevin right
would you have anything to say mr.
president thank you I'm Mike summers and
presidency of the American Petroleum
Institute the folks around this table
represent the American ever an energy
revolution we want to thank you for
everything that you've done to support
that revolution and we want to make sure
that revolution come continues after
this pandemic crisis is solved important
meeting this time as you know prices all
across the country
public health crisis and an economic
crisis as you've heard and as you know
for everyone around this table the
energy sector has been a huge part of
the economic success and boom that we've
enjoyed over the last several years and
the combination of the economic harm of
the coronavirus crisis combined with the
Saudis and Russians waging economic
warfare on jobs in this country it's
been a perfect storm in the energy
sector and I'll tell you there are a lot
of jobs there are millions of jobs in
Texas and across the country that are
represented by the men and women around
this table and by energy producers and
there are small producers throughout
Texas and throughout the country who are
who are on the verge of being driven out
of business and so this this meeting I
think is important every one of the
senators in this room has had multiple
conversations with the Saudis leading in
hard on the Saudis and your leadership
in diplomacy with the crown prince had a
big impact getting them to stop flooding
the market and taking advantage of this
crisis and I would underscore one other
issue
the number of the folks around this
table of race I'm very concerned about
is ensuring that that those and energy
in this time of crisis have access to
capital that there are jobs that are
hanging in the balance and and if the
energy producers in this country that
have made America the number one
producer of oil and gas in the world can
access capital to get out of this crisis
we're going to see bankruptcies at a
level this country hasn't seen in
decades and so this meaning and the
continued leadership of your
administration is hugely important thank
you thank you very much today while
you're up the concept inferences I think
we should say in front of the media but
oil reserves story oil the filling up
the national reserves as you know
getting the early great price but at
these prices in fact Kevin and I have
been speaking about it John and I have
been speaking about it at these prices
you would think you'd want to fill up
every cavity that we have in this
country and there's some areas in
Louisiana and other areas that could be
filled up they hold a lot of oil but at
these prices and it would be good and
would keep everybody working but you
would think you'd want to fill up those
areas what do you think of that look I
think that's exactly right I think it
makes sense in terms of easing the
pressure that is that is threatening
these jobs but it also makes sense for
the taxpayer yeah that's that Strategic
Petroleum Reserve is there in times of
crisis and usually the way the federal
government works is we buy when it's
expensive and we sell when it's cheap we
actually have an opportunity now that by
when it's cheap I think it was
inexcusable that Democratic leadership
and the House and Senate blocked that in
this bill we passed last week and I
think Congress needs to go back and
it was in the bill yep and then the
speaker came in and that's the one thing
when she held this bill up for the
number of days does she remove $20 over
$20 well there are too many demographics
that want to see little jobs go I think
you should go back Kevin I think you
should go back and see John if you guys
could go back and do a separate bill and
beyond that you know I think it's 75
billion barrels right now to fill it up
that's not that much so it's fairly in
pretty good shape
but we have other areas that are bigger
frankly than we could fill up too but it
does prices we should be you should be
pumping it up so maybe you guys could
check on and see what you can do but I
don't think anyone can reject it
nobody can reject it so just one thing
mr. president the department the
interior manages a large portion of land
and part of the offshore and one of the
things we've done over the last 15 days
is you had the slowest bread we have
really had our inspectors out on the
front lines working to make sure that
the production that's taking place is a
Cranham as safe and a responsible manner
and thank everybody for their
cooperation in that these jobs are so
important to the American people and and
important that we make sure that we
daughter eyes across parties to he's the
biggest landlord in the country meaning
is called interior interiors a lot of
land when you look at it thank you great
job me doing so did mr. president thank
you thank you sir Thank You bishop
my name's Dan Burke I served the
president with the Secretary of Energy
with regard to the storage mr. president
having the announcement went to market
this week for 30 million barrels now
what standing the desire of the Congress
not to give us any money to pursue this
idea we have found an alternative
financing mechanism so that we can take
it you would I actually wasn't worried
about so that we could win dictate
Romero I'm sorry sir what are you paying
anyone it's gonna be a little bit
flexible pressure where they may be
paying us that's gonna be a little bit
so we're gonna go negatives yeah might
get transmitted but mr. president I just
want to do now and for the industry
players who are here we're moving very
aggressively we're using every tool that
we have at the US Department of Energy
not only to provide immediate relief for
this particular industry and the economy
itself but also the look for
technologies that over time will reduce
the cost structure for the entire
industry so we're moving on this as
aggressively as we can sir thank you for
your leadership
did you check out other areas where you
can store oil
and there's some very big ones bigger
than what we have now and at these
prices you should do it just really fill
it up right yes sir
the tank okay Bob lighthouse you've been
so great and this is your meeting really
but Bob it's been some of the best trade
deals ever done in our country
and one of them is kicked it actually
kicked it on April 1st and that's with
China and I hope they're buying a lot
but the trade deals are working china's
good we're on track with the USMC
everybody on this entry was very shy
that's pretty he just wants to make
deals in saloon then you've done a great
job thank you very much we will have a
news conference in about five o'clock
5:15 maybe then so we'll see it a little
while we'll answer questions but this is
a great group of leaders and we've got
to make sure that we preserve and even
make greater our energy industry and I
want to thank all of the senators and
congressmen and the boss here for being
here and for working so hard they are
I'll tell you what they are calling me
constantly they want your industry to be
successful and they really and they're
going to make it that way we're all
going to make it that way so I'll see
you at five o'clock and same place we
look forward to it thank you
rotavirus we got the new guidance would
anybody like to beat this and how about
you do you want to be tested I would
love to be tested actually I think all
of us might add we might be able to
question no you know what I like it
let's test these guys you know they gave
us I think some of millions of jobs
listen we think if I said millions of
jobs if anybody wants to be tested
[Applause]